in this story for the post millennial
they say Joe Biden appears to fall
asleep during meeting with Maui
survivors now I know I know all of these
news out they're trying to be very
careful over litigation they don't want
to say that Joe Biden did fall asleep
despite the fact that on video he
appears to fall asleep and they say
appears to fall asleep I am just going
to say this upon review of this video
which I'll play for you here Joe Biden
is falling asleep
I mean I think it's fair to say he
appears to be falling to have fallen
asleep
I am going to say I believe Joe Biden
fell asleep
yeah
Charlie Kirk says octogenarian Joe Biden
seems to be falling asleep while meeting
with survivors of the Maui fires fires
yep it just like pops up look at this
he's like oh look at this is funny his
eyes slowly open he's like wait he might
have died for a second
wow he definitely just woke up there
yeah he's sleeping okay I I think it's
fair to say he appears to be sleeping
because he did we want to be precise
when you sleep you do appear to be
sleeping I'm gonna say outright yo that
guy's asleep yeah when you're asleep you
do appear to be sleeping I know he fell
asleep I'm not mad at Joe Biden for
falling asleep
I am not mad at Joe Biden for falling
asleep I am met the people who voted for
him yeah
um 80 year old man so I want ice cream
you're like okay Grandpa come on ice
cream was that fine I'll get you ice
cream then he takes a crap in his pants
and everyone's got to smell it and it's
like dude I'm not mad at the old man
who's trying to live his life and wants
to live his best life I met the people
who enabled someone who was incapable uh
better yet not to poop the pants thing
let's say 80 year old guy with really
bad videos I would drive the car and
you're like no grandpa the 67 Corvette
you should not be driving you're gonna
get an egg I wanna drive okay fine you
can drive any crashes it I was like okay
come on man at a certain point loved
ones need to be alike Joe come on he's
the cash cow Rich if you're rich grandpa
I was like I'm gonna drive and you know
he's not healthy for it but he's like
he's the one that's giving you your
monthly allowance so you're like we have
no choice if we don't let him drive he
cuts us off dude wow he's a big guy dude
it's amazing just just let him be
president even if even if the
pedestrians are at risk just let him
drive no they're like if he's the
president our checks are gonna get so
much bigger than when he was a vice
president yup triple quadruple yeah so I
saw this story I saw the video of
everyone flicking him off in Hawaii it's
crazy they're all screaming F you at him
as he drives through because 700 I ain't
doing nothing some guy was holding up a
sign saying the people of Ukraine Got
1700 if you break down how much money
was sent to Ukraine for the war and the
people of Lahaina only got 700 yeah Joe
Biden is a is a is a corporeal body that
Democrats needed to go up against Trump
that's all he is and so of course he's
falling asleep people voted for this
they were like I'd rather have this than
Donald Trump throwing paper towels to
people are you kidding I'd rather have
Trump they're throwing paper towels to
people at least paper towels you can dry
stuff you can wipe your hands with Joe
Biden's sleeping is is nothing it's
negative it's it's it's it's it's chaos
yeah it's a it's a puppetry he's that's
and I think that's a lot of what this
administrative class wants is puppets I
think Vivek was talking I keep bringing
them up but they were talking on Sean
Ryan great great Episode by the way Sean
Ryan spectacular interviewer about how
John fetterman like what the hell they
put a guy with brain damage from a
recent stroke in to Congress but did you
see the picture of him because they need
a puppet but not only that but the thing
is he's in you he's kind of immune from
criticism if you put like so if you
attack John fetterman then they're gonna
go ahead and say well you're you're
taught you're attacking someone that's
that's disabled it's ableism for
attacking him and it's like wait a
minute
is it too close no oh the mustache yeah
I mean mustache
glasses on I honestly think that's a
better look it's about oh yeah you know
I probably would like the guy if I knew
him one on one but man why would you put
something like that in concert I'd
probably like him if I was able to
actually communicate with him and
understand where he came from but I
think that time has long since passed
I'm not tend to be mean I'm saying the
dude can't communicate anymore like you
watch these videos and the Democrats are
clapping for things that are incoherent
yeah like I mean it doesn't the
Democrats the person doesn't matter
whether it's Dianne Feinstein who who
just had her her Handler tell her just
say yay because she started talking
about something that was a non-sequitur
or something uh whether it's this guy
whether it's Kamala Harris who can
barely complete a sentence Mitch
McConnell Joe Biden well Mitch McConnell
had like a brain fart stroke no one
knows in the middle of giving a speech
yeah it's fair enough Fair there are old
people on both sides um so fair enough
yeah Mitch McConnell he should get out
of the turtle
um but the point I think the point that
I'm making though is is the left does
doesn't really have a whole lot of you
know differing opinions on it they're
all very in lockstep so it doesn't
matter who the person is yeah because
look at Dianne Feinstein yeah exactly
you know she was her daughter as power
of attorney yeah and she it was really
funny she was gone for what three months
her daughter has power of attorney and
for some reason she's allowed to stay in
her in her seat her that means that she
her daughter has to make all of her
choices for her all of her her daughter
has the position yeah her daughter is
her daughter technically is probably the
uh unelected uh yeah
I don't know what deal for sure is but
Feinstein was out for what was like
three months was it and then she was
like I've been here the whole time yeah
it's like it's and the fact that we and
we allow the hospital we allow this I
just don't know how to do it peacefully
legally to remove the old people and put
like fresh intelligent young people in
you don't room you don't have the
ability to remove or to to affect Dianne
Feinstein because you know you
well possibly but you're not her
constituent you know what I mean you
couldn't do anything about her the only
thing we can do is is we could get some
kind of Constitutional Amendment that
says you have either a age limit or
there's some kind of test or you know
cognitive test or whatever
um but because of the way that our
government is is set up you don't have
the ability to do anything about
fetterman in Pennsylvania because you're
not as constituent you know I mean so
you writing to his you know office like
being like yo you should resign to be
like well who's this clown from Maryland
you know they or whatever they wouldn't
care so I also think that in the case of
Joe Biden that the DNC and Democrats
were really drawn to someone who is so
it's going to say out to lunch but I
think that's too nice a term but someone
who is just so not there because when
you contrast him with you know Chieftain
Donald J Trump I think they really hated
Trump in part policies aside because he
was a strong man right in other words a
bull in a china shop you didn't know
what he was going to do but implied in
that is that what he wanted to do he
hadn't agenda he had an idea you
couldn't and I'm sure we would disagree
on this but you couldn't easily
manipulate him to the extent that you
could just get Joe Biden to like do
anything and I would almost argue the
fact that the hunter Biden hard drive
all the compromising business deals in
some way that was like the insurance
policy that they wanted on a candidate
like Joe Biden because they they know
that they could control him and I think
that's why they're so drawn to these
politicians who are just so like
listless vessels I'll use a quote uh I
like that phrase because they're the
opposite right thesis antithesis of
Donald Trump you can't you it's a lot
easier to control someone like that and
I have to say just to juxtapose what
went on in Maui today and it goes back
to my point about the strong man with
what you see going on at the brick
Summit right now the Brazil Russia India
China South Africa I mean talk about an
abdication of America from from the
world stages you see all these various
deals energy deals being pursued not in
the US dollar but in Petro dollars and
and really the dedolarization of the
global economy it's because of actions
like that from Joe Biden it's the
absence of a strong man an actual figure
on the world stage who has I mean I
would say Vision but actually just has
the brain cells to like create Vision
internally that I think is why you're
seeing really America just fall into
utter utter chaos on the world stage in
these other countries really overstep so
it's they should send Phenom in Hawaii
he what I could maybe do a better job I
he would I think so that's the point
yeah he would be saying incoherent
things but he'd be awake you
know what else can I say yeah it is it
is an absurd reality for this country
when the man who can't read or I'm sorry
he can't understand words being said to
him and struggles to speak would do a
better job than the president who fell
asleep
yeah he also Joe Biden went down there
and in true Joe Biden form started
talking about how he understood what
they were going through because he
experienced something very similar to
his kitchen oh my God his kitchen caught
on fire one time and that was the the I
know what you're going through oh I know
that your child burned alive one time my
kitchen caught on fire and oh my kid
died of brain cancer yeah I have a cat
my cat almost we almost lost that cat
when he talks to the military I don't I
don't I don't care to rag on these like
single singular statements that Biden
makes and things like this where
everyone's like
I I get it he's garbage and I'm just
kind of like yeah yeah yeah you know if
you want you like to be fair you could
pull quotes from every president and be
like that was a bit tactless my bigger
concern is he fell asleep yeah it's like
his overall condition is really weird
you can you can have you can make a
mistake in a blunder by saying some
stupid story and I can pull up any
president anytime who had a quote that
was that was not so good
but come on the dude can't stay awake
it was Hawaii it was used in Hawaii time
so it's three hours earlier let's be
kind
nobody in Hawaii no let's not no he was
in Hawaii oh I'm being fully sarcastic
it's not three hours five hours
it doesn't it doesn't matter if you
can't do the job don't ask for it I'm
not gonna if someone hundred pound woman
is like I'd like to be a firefighter I'd
be like can you carry a 150 pound person
up and down the stairs I will push I got
no beef with women but I'm like come on
this job requires you to save someone's
life push the button to have Joe Biden
resign and have Kamala Harris become
president right now I would love that I
gotta be honest I think kamalair Kamala
would be worse it's it's yes do you know
what she's gonna do okay I would rather
have a president sleeping than to have
Kamal Harris go fire
is bad
and I'm here because of Fire
and everyone's gonna be like what that's
the interesting argument would you
rather have a vacant non-president or a
bad president that's like ruthlessly
evil and horrible just check it out
she's quite fetterman would would be
there and he would do better than both
of them not by much but he'd be like
yeah the the fire and you people get
hurt
fiberglass the the fire and I'm like
well I can see some indignation in his
voice and he asked people to get hurt so
I'll take that water
on fire we understand
yeah yeah Kamala she would say I love
those quotes from her she's like
children are the community because the
community has children and you're like
what I believe why children but I mean
the future my having a president that's
asleep at the wheel is got to be worse
than a psycho I'm not saying kamo's
psycho evil but like it's got to be
worse than having a psycho even wanted
to keep a man a man that was that she
had evidence that she knew that he was
innocent she kept him on death row yes
she is evil do you know what that guy's
name was oh man but I'd rather have evil
and aware and awake and alive and
intelligent than stupidly why do you
want smart evil as opposed to dumb evil
well it's opposed to nothing smart evil
or no president I'd rather have a smart
evil president than no President Joe
Biden no falling asleep like where's his
relationship with the Russians where's
his relationship with the Chinese spy
balloon where's his relationship with
the disaster relief of Maui if he's not
doing anything he's not messing anything
up yeah but then there's just it's all
incoherence yeah chaos I mean I don't
know what's better
a sane rational I don't know like Marcus
Aurelius type well I mean obviously
Marcus Aurelius is like you know he's
one of the the greatest Cincinnati in
history you know I think because our our
country has such checks and balances
that I feel like an evil president would
get overwritten a lot of times by the
rest of the branches of government no I
disagree I think I mean the kind that
would start a war that killed a million
people in the Middle East yeah the evil
ones get away with it because the evil
ones bribe those beneath them and the
good ones don't thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time